so what we do a lot of is we actually
take data science work we bring into
companies and in order to do that
especially as what Peter was talking
about you start running into a lot of
strange scenarios where standard tools
don't actually assist very well in doing
data science work and so you need a
different tool set and so some people
use are some people use sequel in a
various combination of other tools and
so we elected to go with scalable Python
inside of a sequel engine and so
what-what the reason why we we had to do
this is one data science is requiring us
to leverage different types of inputs
that go beyond simple structure and so
that means being able to actually parse
text on the fly and work with image
files and work with with video files and
so forth the data size is also
increasing and so that scalability
component becomes absolutely required
and sequel especially to to data
scientist and analysts it's just really
easy to use it's really fast in terms of
being able to transform data into
workable data sets but at the at the end
of the day you need an analytics
language and a much more complex
language that will let you work with
these different new data types and so we
need a language as data scientist in
order to be able that goes beyond sequel
and actually one that's well supported
and has a lot of excess packages that
allow us to do work and allow us to do
that in a repeatable fashion so with
that one's so with with that we ended up
having to create a platform in order to
support the work that we did and that's
the the huge data platform and so it's
broken out into three key components
there's a distributed sequel layer which
actually allows you whenever you make
your calls to run them all on each
individual node and then bring the
results back and work with that and then
there's a distributed analytics layer
that we wrote that actually uses Python
in it in order to power those functions
and then there are manual controls for
Python and our calls so that means you
can actually on each node code in Python
and then bring those results back and so
what I'm going to talk a little bit
about is is the paradigm for that and
why we've elected to use Python inside
sequel so actually role you want to if
you want to yeah go in
I just keep a slider ball one of the
reasons we pick Python just as a base
wanted to be something more more
powerful than stored procedures sicko
has nice or procedures but they're not
they're not as handy to handling a lot
of data we wanted to be able to use some
user-defined packages there's all these
packages out there on the Python
community that we want it to be able to
leverage and then we also want to to
give the user the ability to write their
own functions and to expand the at the
sequel universe just because at some
point we can't support all of it and
it's and the user has the knowledge so I
figured at that point it's they should
be the ones writing those functions so
one of our we had three main goals one
of them was to to be scalable you
obviously wanted to make sure that we
could run on a master worker paradigm
you know where the master does similar
work but then the other workers do most
of it the other one is reduced time
spender analytics we wanted to find the
right language that a lot of people knew
and that a lot of people are in a lot of
stuff on it and Python was easy to
integrate too so that's what we like
that and then we want it to be
extensible mean that we could build
packages that we could we could leverage
for our clients users to leverage for
everybody in the under other enterprise
so that's why we we pick Python let's
see okay sorry our approach was to make
sure we obviously like sequel I think
most people are aware of how sequel
works so we wanted to make sure that
that we stay within sequel and wanted to
start we had to establish some custom
data types and functions and make it
easy to be able to to just swap data
between the Python later than the sequel
but in wanted to make it where you had
to to know what the of the background is
doing the ability to create some
deserted objects make sure that we you
could be able to create your own custom
data types and and get package taxes you
know being able to access any package
out there only fight on community I
think that was a big one for us for that
we we came up with a couple
things we first so we came up with a
couple data types there are embedded
within our Python we have the HD
resurrect which is a data type that we
that the HD the huge data engine uses to
send all the data back to the to the
Python code we create on numeric data
type sequel had a nice when we had a
nice one but we wanted to use the sixty
five digits of precision so we use the
HD numeric we obviously wanted to be
able to want you to your processing on
Python be able to insert data back into
a database so we created a HD HD insert
but the biggest ones are the distributor
execution we built the HD execute remote
and on Val and it allows you to write a
function and a function that is executed
an order on all the data nodes which
I'll get into the data struc the
architects in a little bit and last one
we wanted to be able to do query store
caching of the data because on some of
those problems you want to you maybe
want to do multiple passes through the
data and sequels only a one pass but by
doing it this and being able to store
cash in it you're able to do multiple
passes on your Python data and you don't
have to be wearing that data every
single time so I'll get to the so here's
our technical specs the way that our
system is a sign and we have the end
user on the left side we have our master
server which is the one that establishes
all the communication make sure that
knows what all the data nodes are which
are on the right side you can have as
many data nodes as you want we have join
servers which we use in sequel for joint
queries they're the kind of like
memcache service in a way if you want to
think about it that way so the master
server is the one that interfaces with
the user and based on what the user
query is it either sensor to all the
nodes you got the process of a master or
sensor two nodes sensor data back to the
master that's additional processing and
then sense it back to the user so India
here's a simple example and referencing
this side we have the users one the user
sends a function so like
function from from a table and that
function is a Python function the master
server takes that and insist that he
needs to send it to all the remote at
that point is sent staff on that query
with the function to a delivery mode the
remote execute the query all at the same
time once you get the data ready sends
it back to the master on step 4 once
it's on step for the master decides if
you want to if if you wrote on your
Python function to do more processing
you'll be done at the master or if
that's all you need it then you'll just
send it right back to the user and then
that's where that's what I'll be done
and I'm going to get into some examples
so you can make a little bit more sense
we have two types of Python
implementations we have a function in
our procedure on a function as you can
see here and sorry for the guise of
where you define it you know like on
this one is supposed to be a someone
where you just add one to whatever
function whatever variable you pass that
one gets executed on all the remotes
once you pass it and you pass that in
SSL as a query statement as the sequel
statement so all he does is sends out
the query returns back as if it was a
regular function like an average one on
average but like length now the
procedure on your hand allows you to be
able to call your own specific your own
specific functions within it at that
point if you want to do like a someone
or where you call a call a function get
some data from the database you want to
be able to do some extra processing add
extra numbers whatever you want to do
after that you do it at that point and
then you're done so on this one you just
call on the sequel interface you just
call the procedure and that's it and
then all the code is in there yes right
well you attack you write it on your
sequel interface so this is the picture
like your see if you're if you're on my
simple you can use a my sequel workbench
or or Microsoft via the studio you're
inside your sequel
and then you write this and here's where
you to find the entire function or the
procedure and you write it yourself and
then then you execute a right after that
so all this is within sequel it's not
outside of sequel right now i'm not i'm
not aware of i know the only ones that
comes up on some some type of Python I
know isn't it ISA and they support some
type of Python but you have to be aware
of more via the network communication
you have to do a lot more right here we
try to make it a lot easier this is our
own our own flavor of database we're all
our core ourselves so this this high Sun
foundry excuse I inside the database
correct any edit database yeah actually
make that specific we wrote that
database ourselves so so all that stuff
runs inside the database inside of all
the master that we wrote in India the
workers india and joiners yes well we
when we started with the data we wrote
the database first we wanted to create a
distributed database so we yeah I mean
he wants to answer that it PL python is
not a distributed version of Python you
can call PL Python and you can call you
can write code it interfaces with
postgres that way but what our goal was
really was to create a distributed
python system so that when you call a
piece of Python you can actually if
there was a function he went over called
execute remotes on what you're actually
doing is you're actually sending the
python code back to the data nodes on a
distributed system to execute that piece
of code against data on that data node
generate some results and send that back
to the bastard node we wanted to do that
in a way that was totally easy for the
user the user didn't have to worry about
communications or pickling of the data
back and forth
to the user they just called a function
and got back a results from all the data
nodes and merge those results together
and that was it so that was that was
what that's how it's come a little bit
different than the pl Python version
yeah so we started off with a we
designed an MPP system to run on
different nodes in sequel and in one day
people kept asking for additional
functionality and we'd have to go code
it and see and we said we're tired of
this so so to solve that problem we said
well let's integrate Python into it so
that people are data scientists and our
other users can write their own
distributed code and load it straight in
without home and come back to the C
programmers so that was kind of how we
got started on a Python and since then
now I'm in the middle of finishing the
distributed our system too so the which
can integrate actually with the Python
system but I won't go into that but
that's what God is going on with
distributed Python system well I have an
internal armed package that just like I
do we have a we have a module implied
column called HDL which is actually
internal to the C code on the database
that's not an external package so when
you write your Python code there's a
list of things you can call in that
package for example execute query and
execute query on remote nodes and stuff
like that so that's how it works I'm
sorry did I did I ruin your next slide
my next line just all right all right so
yes we have that I'll get to that in a
second we all like I mentioned for we
get our own HD rest object which all it
really is is just the collection is a
collection of a list of tuples and then
we use that for when we send a query
with in Python to get the data back we
start on that or if we return in data
back from Python back to the sequel
layer we use that as well just send it
back and we can send any data type but
it just makes it a lot easier for us to
manage
CEO / yeah right like I said they owe
and all Python functions recognize this
object we made it so whatever package
you downloading and you send the HD
resurrect it really all the functions
think of it as a list so you should be
able to handle it just fine and the main
thing is it's a once you define it and
once you started putting data into it it
holds to the memory so you're always
having their pages data in and out so so
it's like an object that you can you can
continue working on it as your
processing your entire data which was a
big deal for for a data scientist as he
mentioned we are making one of our main
function sees HD query so we think
Python you especially if you write a
procedure you want to be able to get
data out of your sequel tables so you
even though you're inside inside sequel
you still want to be able to get that
data out and do some processing and then
maybe put it right back in or return it
back to user so we have our function
called HD query on that one what it does
is you can execute it on the master
level and then you'll go out and get the
data from all the nodes or if you
executed on on execute remote that
function will go into each node get the
data out and stay in there do whatever
processing you have and then send the
data back to the master which is very
handy when you're trying to just work on
special with just the small parts of the
of the data because all the nodes are
working at the same time but you also
want to do some extra processing so it's
extremely handy for us here's a pistol
simple example here we have we always
have the import HD which is our package
and here we have HD query and like that
we just select some data out of the
database out of the actual database and
all we do is just return it right back
and that's an HD right object and you
return it back to the user here you
execute it and you return it back to the
user like I said the idea at that point
is here this is executed at the master
level once you get your data most of the
time you want to do some more to it and
then you return it back to the user or
you can put it right back on the
database so the idea is to be able to to
go through your data much more than just
some of a single pass or be able to be
to apply any other
is that you have so that's what I seek
where is extremely powerful on our
system it also takes care of all the app
and networking you don't need to know
that it we're all your data nodes are
you just once you run that it gets sent
to the engine and the engine goes to all
the data nodes and it turns back your
your result and like I mentioned the
idea is also to be able to put it right
back into the database you want to do
some processing and then you want to put
it back into the database so someone
else can use it or or you can use it for
another procedure or or another on our
team member to do it so same thing on
this we do an HD query we get the data
out we put on the res object then here
we create a table inside the ax the huge
data engine and here we just insert the
data into that into that at that table
like I said at that point it's now it's
a table you can access through sequel we
like anything else like with a simple
select and and no one knows that he was
actually done through Python so that
Doug like I said that's that's very
handy when we're selecting and
reinserting data ascii mention we have a
one of our strongest on the execute
remote the the advantage of the
executors emojis you might want to build
a function at assertive function where
each node pulls up a little bit of the
data whatever data has on that data node
you want to do some extra processing and
then you want to return back to the
master the master gets it all back
together and then you want to do some
more processing on that advantage so
that is it's all distributed so now
you're writing your own distributed
function you do some small processing
you do some heavy process may be on the
other nodes and then you send it back to
the master and the master that some
additional processing after that like I
said device so that is they're all
running in parallel the master does the
final aggregation if you need to do some
final obligation and then you send it
right back the advantage of this
function it handles all your connection
between the worker and the nodes it does
you don't need to know what what the
notes are it pickles the arguments and
it ships it over to the work to the
worker nodes you can have multiple
arguments many to write one and they
need it compresses the results once but
once it's done processing the data on
the notes it just compresses the results
and sends it right back to the user and
it comes back as a list of all the notes
if you have a hundred note then you're
going to get the result of a hundred
notes each each one is going to be its
own independent little independent tuple
in the list i believe and i'll go
through an example here I make more
sense here so this is a simple example
of our execute remote obviously here's
our here's where our execution path
starts we have HD execute remote and
we're going to pass it function count
days and then we're going to pass it the
function outlook which we got from from
sequel once he goes that then this
function will actually get sent town
days to every single data node execute
data nodes which only does is hey give
me some of that data that you have
locally and then and then return to
length so only that all these doing is
just counting the number of days but
each one is doing it independently at
the exact same time so once you do that
then you get it here which it returns
days now it's a list and that now we
have to go to release and count them all
up and then we return to the the final
the total number of days like I said at
that point execute remote was able to
handle sending the parameters it was
able to handle the return back and then
at that point it's up to you to do
whatever you need to do with that list
that you just got back so at that point
you it's it's on you to be able to to
either return it or or do more or expand
it as much as you can and then at the
end we have our HD rights object to
return it and and send it back to the to
the sequel layer any personal net and I
win Calif ass
hey as I mentioned we also have the
query store it kind of works like a like
a like an HD query where you send out a
query but at the end you'll see you
don't get your data back you just get a
pointer to it which we call it on the HD
HD huge data type so you execute the
query on the remote and then you just
get a pointer right and then once you
get that then the pointer now the master
has this pointer and then you can call
you can do multiple queries after that
Alexa q remotes or anything and you just
pack the pointer and the pointer is
going to look pull that data out of
memory and then do some more processing
that's extremely handy when you're doing
a lot of analytical functions that
requires you to do multiple passes over
the exact same data you don't want to be
calling that data over and over I mean
it's fine when you have only a million
or two million when you have a billion
you don't want each data know to be
doing that every single time so the
equator story handles all the code parts
in as well validation with the function
and parameters and like I mentioned it
returns back the pointers to whatever
structure is on the local servers and
I'll get a little sample here hi a
simple example here obviously we start
here on our store test here we call HD
query store and we just passed a
sinkhole a simple query back to the DI
data nodes on the data nodes it just
looks you know just like the f1 from
tests and puts it into a pointer so now
data is a collection of pointers on the
remote node once we have those pointers
now we can do store step where we can
execute on the remote and we pass the
pointer and that pointer is going to be
for each data nodes which they don't
know will know what will pass this
pointer so know what data to work on and
on that mode we'll just go through the
data at the pointer load it up into many
loads enough memory and then you can do
your iteration through it and then you
just return the sum then that's how I
will return here here no come back here
as you can see we you don't you don't
know that that is a memory you know it's
a memory buddy we we try to make it easy
on that so so
the user doesn't need to know what it's
actually happening it just knows the
memory and it knows you can call it
again it's very easy to follow through
and then like you know we have here we
execute a couple of times and then there
actually was supposed to be executed
multiple times you can execute that data
over and over and over and over again
the advantage of that like I mentioned
is ability to be able to work through
your data is your save data on the
server it it makes it a lot easier when
you don't have to load that data all
over again I like i said here's here's
example obviously this number is wrong
because if that function got executed
like 10 times but i didn't i didn't add
it i do you have run out of space so
here's how you will see the data and
here's how you would call it through
sequel and that's it take place for
tonight and I think that's okay and i
think i were really fast so that's all I
have the key will join me now and help
me with some other Q&A yes the party
libraries chemport him yes and that is a
really good trust phone right now we
have to do it manually so our data
scientists will come to us and say hey I
really want the pandas library I really
want those and raw will usually go load
it onto all the different machines but
in the future we probably will have a
way to automate that kind of right now
when we build a machine for a client or
something we kind of load all the
standard scientific and analytical
packages but you're right if they need a
new when we have to add it but that will
be a feature enhancement but what it is
coming like the other day all needed so
mom yeah the latitude or longitude from
a specific address what we use we loaded
in the car
we loaded the the google the pie geodata
i think is called or something like that
and at that point we just we were able
to import it and just are using those
functions so it's it's extremely handy
but yeah for right now we kind of have
to do a little bit manually yeah yeah
it's dealing with 30 days it's it's a
difficult challenge I mean obviously you
know that I like that python has built
in some built-in functions that kind of
helps you with that one of my favorite
ones it tom is log data like weblog data
we get it in if you just get it as a
text string it certainly harder part but
using your regular sequel tools we we
actually wrote somewhere it actually
does the splitting and how to do the 10
take out the values based on the
splitting oh my oh my expertise our or
expertise but for my experience I try to
write some Python function to try to
identify some of them just writing out a
lot of exceptional is based out of
Python it's it's it's hard but I mean
it's a which I try to use as much Python
as possible when I'm trying to read that
data and try to identify if it's if it's
a number of it's not we wrote this one
where it's extremely handy where you go
through each column and when you turn
every every a through C you turn into an
A and then every number you turn into a
nine and that went and then you do a
group by on that so at that point you're
able to see ok I have ninety-nine
percent of them are all a's but then
there's this one this three or four
right here that are actually nice and
then you can then you're able to look
into those because at that point it just
kind of narrows down your point of view
of what you're looking for so add that
to me is one of the most handy is
function at all just one of the things
we talk about a lot is Aquarius how
Lanier is the query
environment and what that means is
depending on top query can it be
executed completely in parallel or can
some of we've done in parallel and some
of the processing has to be done back on
a master but the great thing about data
etl work like you're talking about is
that become completely in parallel so
once you've got your dirty data loaded
and you find some Python package out
there that you want to run and clean it
up that could be that runs in parallel
on every note so how fast and you want
that to run is simply a function of how
many data knows you have for most of
things I mean usually what I do and in
the python is i'll just i'll return like
i'll have a print statement or i'll have
some kind of what i'm trying to debug
and I'll just return out as a function
from the sequel cow so when I run my
sequel you know command it'll just
return whatever i'm trying to debug as
the output of the function taking skills
here it's kind of a way to see a console
in a way but but you get it to a sequel
no our system does have the console well
I talk what just right
it really is up to the user at that
point you can't run it so it all runs on
master and if you have a data set that
is small enough you might you might see
that that actually works right so some
stuff yes but as you start getting into
the bigger data and the more but yeah
the more complex data you'll realize
that you know what I can't be bringing
all these data back to master you're
going to have to start thinking it is a
client-server model it's not like a
peer-to-peer model so in a sense you are
executed sequentially because you're
going to if the match is going to wait
for all the data knows to complete
execution before is their control
returns on the master to Europe to your
code so while it is distributed system
it or is you not having all like these
events going between all the machines
and everything like you wouldn't appear
to be your assistant right yeah they got
one right here just for more information
about how what is this large estate uh
yeah oh yeah and that's a function of
that sound record yeah I mean yeah we
have one that is about 15 to 18 billion
rows and that one is running on on our
main production system which is 112 data
nodes which you know it is pretty fast
but then you get into the problem of if
you're just doing a simple query it will
be really fast but not if you start
doing some queries like aggregation or
or thing or count distinct where someone
data has to come back to a master then
you're gonna suffer a little bit because
it can be completely distributed the
goal from day one the golden day one was
I wanted the problem that you just
to be a hardware problem and not a
software problem if we needed it to be
faster or handle more I wanted them to
be able to go out and buy more computers
I'm not from that back to me for the
solution I want to be we need to call
down so that there's a base on my screen
there's always sort of a bottleneck if
you reach like hundra's you know you
think you can go to Selden but maybe
they were comic yeah yeah you're right
and it depends on the type of query
you're running through them you know if
you start getting into joins complicated
joints and stuff like that you can and
that's why on this latest production
system put a 40 gigabyte network on it
which to solve a lot of foam we also get
into the situation where you got so many
to so many data nodes and yeah you're
processing on the stata in parallel look
great but then you gotta bring back to
your debt to your master node for the
final aggregation well now that you have
so many data nodes that could be quite a
little arduous task so sometimes we'll
actually found will you actually will
multi-purpose the joiners will actually
go to the joiners first they'll go out
the data nodes do the processing get to
get the data back to these machines that
got a ton of memory then do consolidate
like a pre aggregation step and then get
back to the master for the final
aggregation and so that's one of the
techniques we use to handle the higher
note situation that's exactly what we
got into and we started when we've got
our 112 notes system that we have like
hey it's running really fast in a
back-end data nodes but now the Masters
running slower okay so we had to like
think about that second question is that
of course is higher data contents but
have you ever done any performance
measurement again also system like oral
code using Java I think there's maybe
some no we haven't done any any
performance on that yet we've done it
because post browse on my sig for but we
don't have a normal system yeah and we
haven't tested any of their like the
Java functionality or stuff like that
and and no way we haven't gotten to that
and you know and some of it is not
completely just about speed we don't
like to get into a speed as long as it
we find our data analyst is like look
they have like limits of can run em like
it runs under a certain amount of time
no okay I've noticed that when things
start getting them word
two hours or then they start getting mad
you know I'm not saying that stuff runs
that long but you have different
expectations we also think of ease of
use and that's one of the things were
like what the python is i can code up a
distributed algorithm python in a day
which would take me a whole week and see
and so can look at other people you know
the data scientists are all other people
who you know so it's some of it is that
you know by using a python yeah it's
going to run a little slower in python
but it only took me a day to develop it
for a week and well okay so the slower
so you add some more notes on to it or
something you know it's like kinda funny
doesn't like a little trade-off there
that helped a little bit
yeah I think we must spoke because of
Dana dusted on bills yeah so he is
talking about is when you do what we
call it worries for that's when you
execute akari on remote nodes on a data
nodes it will load that data in the
memory to a certain point it's an exposé
in an internal Python structure at some
point of will star as a building so yeah
you don't booty is a sequel system at
the heart of it it's a sequel system
luna we have a lot of users that will
create just a big Park our tables
staging tables and bring the data in as
well text and then they'll use Python or
whatever to clean that up and select
that into a more structured home
well a TI like I seven since it is a
sequel system you know it is a
structured data bases than button but I
mean you can get around that by just
creating one field in your table right a
big blob or big text field loading
uploading whatever you want into it a
bunch of log data or text found and xml
file data and then running python code
parsed XML data on a per row basis and
converts that into a structured format
or process it you know in place we have
users that do that that will blow it in
and log data keep it in that format and
then write Python functions to parse it
all apart and then they can call those
Python functions from standard equal so
they can treat they're basically
creating a view using the Python a
Bridget so they can do select onto those
log tables without them being in the
structured format it's going to run a
little slower that way because it's not
you know that has bila processing but
since there had data coming all the time
they don't want to take the Conn to
select it all into a new table because
they don't want snapshots they want the
real time analysis
right we used to five us one day to my
right and we 42 line protocol right now
we just put a month people in the market
offline so most people use the market ox
of my seagull pool in triangle that use
the microphone in Toronto key when you
load that data it is a round robin
insert so it all it's all distributed I
don't want to say equally but almost
equally it's in all the data nodes as
many as you have